Okay. Hallo, schon guten Tag.
So, guten Tag.
Ja, mein Name ist, ich bin Frau Dr. Shahi.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzärztin tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen die Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja. Hauptsache jemand guckt nach mir, ja.
Okay, okay. Falls Sie Fragen haben, können Sie mich jederzeit unterbrechen.
Erst brauche ich Ihre persönliche Daten, dann gehen wir mit Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden durch, okay?
Ja, okay.
Okay, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Nadia Winter.
Nadia Winter. Okay, das ist sehr deutlich, aber können Sie kurz buchstabieren, damit ich nicht falsch schreibe?
Ja, der Vorname ist N-A-D-J-A.
Nadia. Okay.
Und Winter ist wie Sommer, W-I-N-T-E-R, Winter.
Wie die Jahreszeit.
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Winter?
Ich bin noch 46 Jahre alt.
46, okay. Ziemlich jung. Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 08.07.79.
79, okay. Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Winter?
Ich bin 1,67.
Okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ja, ich wiege so 71 Kilo ungefähr.
71 Kilo. Okay, Frau Winter, was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ja, also heute Morgen hatte ich mit einem so heftiges Herzrasen, da habe ich richtig Angst bekommen.
Und ja, mir geht es eigentlich schon seit einer ganzen Weile irgendwie nicht so gut.
Und zwar, also bin ich eigentlich so unruhig, ich bin so zitterig, ich kann nachts nicht schlafen.
Und ja, ich bin unheimlich nervös und reizbar.
Und ja, also heute Morgen dieses Gefühl, dass das Herz mir wirklich bis zu den Ohren rausschlägt, ja.
Ja. Boah, das war sehr beängstigend.
Und ja, es ist wirklich was Merkwürdiges passiert.
Ich bin zwei Mal in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen war ich zwei Mal ganz kurz ohnmächtig.
Okay.
Ja, das hat mir jetzt schon ein bisschen schreck gemacht, aber heute Morgen eben diese Herzgeschichte,
da habe ich mir gedacht, jetzt gehst du aber doch endlich mal ins Krankenhaus.
Okay, wie viel Mal waren Sie ohnmächtig?
Das ist zwei Mal passiert. Also immer nur ganz kurz, ja.
Okay, sind Sie gestürzt, wenn Sie ohnmächtig waren?
Nein, Gott sei Dank ist mir eigentlich nichts passiert.
Also das eine Mal war zu Hause und das andere war bei der Arbeit, da habe ich aber Pause machen können
und habe eigentlich am Tisch gesessen und war dann nur kurz weg, ja.
Okay, okay. Fällt Ihnen vielleicht Gedächtnisstörungen?
Das wüsste ich jetzt eigentlich nicht. Also wie gesagt von dieser Ohnmacht,
das kann ich natürlich nicht sagen, also da fehlen mir diese zwei Minuten natürlich klar.
Aber ansonsten glaube ich nicht, dass mein Gedächtnis besonders schlecht ist.
Okay, okay. Und haben Sie jetzt immer noch Herzlösung? Können Sie es durchhalten?
Nein, jetzt ist es zum Glück wieder weg, aber das hat mir solche Angst gemacht,
dass ich gedacht habe, jetzt muss doch mal was passieren, ja.
Haben Sie vorher auch solche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, aber also das ist der erste Mal, diese Unruhe.
Das ist mit dem Herzen das erste Mal, sonst wäre ich sicherlich früher gekommen.
Aber die Unruhe habe ich jetzt schon eine ganze Weile, das merke ich, dass das nicht so gut ist.
Und ja, was mir auch aufgefallen ist, ich habe in letzter Zeit wirklich sehr sehr oft Durchfälle
und habe auch tatsächlich schon ein bisschen Gewicht verloren.
Ich meine, da ist man ja nie so traurig, wenn man ein bisschen Gewicht verliert.
Aber ja, also ich versuche ja ganz normal zu essen und diese ständigen Durchfälle
ist natürlich auch ein bisschen nervig.
Ok, seit wann haben Sie Durchfälle?
Ja, das ist jetzt auch schon so in den letzten Wochen so.
Also in den letzten zwei bis drei Wochen nehme ich an.
Nee, eigentlich schon ein bisschen länger.
Also das ist nicht jedes Mal, aber immer mal wieder, ja.
Ok, schon länger.
Ok, haben Sie auch Bauchkrämpfe?
Naja, mit dem Durchfall habe ich gelegentlich auch mal Bauchkrämpfe,
aber die Schmerzen sind nicht das Hauptproblem, nee.
Ok, also Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Schlafstörungen haben.
Also haben Sie Einschlafstörungen oder Durchschlafstörungen?
Ja, also zunächst fällt mir das Einschlafen schwer und wenn ich dann mal aufwache in der Nacht,
weil irgendwas ist, weil ein Geräusch ist oder weil ich vielleicht auf die Toilette muss oder so,
dann komme ich wieder zurück ins Bett und kann überhaupt nicht wieder einschlafen, ja.
Dann bin ich ganz unruhig.
Ok, haben Sie Probleme mit Atemnot bemerkt?
Nee, das habe ich eigentlich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Ok, haben Sie Husten?
Husten habe ich nicht, nee.
Nee, mit der Atemnuss glaube ich alles ok, ja.
Ok, sehr toll, ganz toll.
Haben Sie sich fiebrig gefühlt?
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber fiebrig habe ich mich eigentlich nicht gefühlt.
Ok, also haben Sie solche Schüttelfrostnachschweiß bemerkt?
Nee, das nicht.
Also mir ist zwar eher warm, aber so richtig schwitzen tue ich eigentlich nicht
und so fiebrig fühle ich mich eigentlich auch nicht.
Ok, Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie in letzter Zeit wegen dem Durchfall ein bisschen abgenommen haben.
Ja, wissen Sie wieviel Kilogramm Sie abgenommen haben und in welcher Zeitraum?
Ja, also das sind so ungefähr drei Kilo, die ich runter habe.
Und ja, das ist vielleicht so ein Vierteljahr.
So, im letzten Jahr, in einem Jahr?
In einem Vierteljahr, in drei Monaten.
Ok, und wie ist es mit Ihrem Appetit?
Eigentlich habe ich schon Appetit.
Und auch in den letzten drei Monaten hat sich Ihr Appetit verändert?
Nee, eigentlich würde ich nicht sagen.
Eigentlich sogar, dass ich sehr gut esse, würde ich behaupten.
Ok, fällt Ihnen, gibt es bestimmte Lebensmittel, die den Durchfall auslöst?
Haben Sie sowas bemerkt?
Das könnte ich jetzt gar nicht sagen.
Eigentlich ist das immer wieder, ich kann das nicht irgendwie einem Lebensmittel zuordnen.
Dass ich sage, was weiß ich immer, wenn ich Kohl esse oder so, dann kriege ich Durchfall.
Oder immer wenn ich Paprika esse, kriege ich Durchfall.
Nee, das kommt immer wieder, egal was ich esse.
Ok, haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen?
Nee, da habe ich zum Glück keine Probleme.
Ok, Frau Winter, haben Sie Bekannte vor Erkrankungen, Kronscherkrankungen?
Ja, ich quäle mich tatsächlich schon seit vielen Jahren rum mit Endometriose.
Endometriose.
Ja, und das ist natürlich oft mit Beschwerden, wenn Sie nach Bauchschmerzen oder Bauchkrämpfen fragen,
da habe ich natürlich dann hin und wieder meine Probleme.
Und das habe ich schon seit ich 18 bin eigentlich.
Aus dem Grund nehme ich Minolet, das soll das so ein bisschen reduzieren, die Beschwerden.
Ok, wie heißt die Medikamente nochmal?
Das ist eine Pille, Minolet heißt die.
Minolet.
Also eigentlich ein Verhütungs, also ein Antikontrazeptivum.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, aber ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie man das nennt.
Minolet.
Minolet, ok, habe verstanden.
Und wie viel Milgramm nehmen Sie ein?
Ich weiß nicht wie die dosiert ist, man nimmt ja jeden Tag seine Tablette.
Ok, und haben Sie sonst welche chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, also bisher war ich immer gesund, ja.
Ok, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Naja, also als Kind habe ich mal die Mandeln rausbekommen und dann, ja so mit 17 ist der Blinddarm rausgekommen, ja.
Ok, und wann war die Mandelentfernung Operation?
Da war ich, also gerade am Ende von der Grundschule, also so 10 Jahre alt ungefähr.
Ok, und mit 17 Jahren haben Sie gesagt die?
Da war der Blinddarm, genau.
Ja, ok.
Frau Winter, bekommen Sie Ihre Wigelblutung regelmäßig?
Ja, natürlich so ein bisschen bedingt durch diese Pille, ne?
Ja.
Die sorgt ja dafür, dass der Zyklus regelmäßig...
Ja, Sie nehmen die Pille jeden Tag in die gleiche Zeit?
Ja, ja natürlich, ja klar.
Ok, ok.
Und, ok, kann es sein, dass Sie schwanger sind?
Nein, das ist ausgeschlossen.
Ok.
Ich lebe mit einer Frau zusammen und habe keinen nennlichen Partner, insofern ist das nicht möglich, dass ich ein Kind bekomme.
Ok, sind Sie, also Sie sind ledig?
Ja, ich bin ledig, aber lebe mit einer Partnerin zusammen.
Ok, ok. Und Sie haben keine Kinder?
Ich habe keine Kinder, nein.
Ok. Und was sind Sie eigentlich beruflich tätig?
Ich arbeite als Schuhverkäuferin.
Schuhverkäuferin?
Schuhverkäuferin, ja genau.
Ok.
Da haben wir natürlich immer zu Beginn der Saison, zu Beginn der Wintersaison und zu Beginn der Sommersaison, wenn es dann die neuen Modelle gibt, ist immer viel Arbeit und wenn alle Leute ihre Garderobe ändern, dann haben wir immer viel Betrieb.
Ja und natürlich auch so im Schlussverkauf, da ist auch immer viel los.
Ok. Frau Winter, haben Sie außer die Pille noch irgendwelche Medikamente, die Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf einnehmen?
Also wenn ich das merke, dass ich so ganz unruhig bin oder dass ich so das Gefühl habe, heute Nacht kann ich überhaupt nicht einschlafen, dann nehme ich wohl mal Baldrian-Tropfen.
Baldrian-Tropfen, ok.
Hier nehme ich aber jetzt nicht jeden Tag, ne?
Ok. Das hilft ja bei Ihnen.
Ja so ein bisschen was bringt es schon, ja.
Ok. Ist bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Also das einzige, was ich weiß, dass ich auf braunes Pflaster allergisch bin.
Braunes Pflaster, ok. Und wie reagieren Sie dagegen?
Ja dann kriege ich halt so rote Pickelchen auf der Haut, da wo der Kleber ist, ne?
Ok. Haben Sie irgendwelche Unverträglichkeiten gegen irgendwelche Lebensmittel?
Nein, also wie gesagt bei dem Durchfall kann ich nicht sagen, dass da irgendwas ist.
Nee generell.
Also ich kann eigentlich alles essen.
Oder ok.
Ich kann alles essen.
Ah super toll. Rauchen Sie, Frau Winter?
Ja ich habe vor drei Jahren aufgehört mit dem Rauchen, da bin ich auch sehr stolz drauf, ja.
Aber ich habe eigentlich auch nie so furchtbar viel geraucht.
Ich habe eigentlich immer nur so sechs Zigaretten am Tag geraucht.
Das war eigentlich mehr so aus Gesellschaft mit den Kollegen oder so.
Aber jetzt seit drei Jahren eben gar nicht mehr.
Ok. Und wie viele Jahre lang haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, das waren so zwölf Jahre.
Ok. Super toll, dass Sie aufgehört haben.
Ja da bin ich auch wirklich glücklich drüber, ja.
Frau Winter, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja also am Wochenende oder wenn es mal was zu feiern gibt oder wenn es ein besonders gutes Essen gibt.
Also mal ein Glas Wein trinke ich schon ganz gerne, ja.
Ok. Und ich habe noch eine Frage, aber bitte nehmen Sie es nicht persönlich an.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, nein, nein, nein, das habe ich nie probiert.
Das ist eine Routinefrage. Wir müssen es vorstellen.
Ok. Und treiben Sie Sport?
Ja ich bin ein bisschen faul, aber doch.
Also im Sommer fahre ich sehr gerne mit dem Fahrrad.
Ja und wenn wir im Urlaub sind, dann spielen wir auch gerne mal Volleyball am Strand oder so.
Aber dass ich jetzt nun regelmäßig Sport mache, im Winter fällt mir das ein bisschen schwerer.
Manchmal mache ich so ein bisschen Gymnastik dann, wenn ich merke, dass mir der Rücken wehtut oder so.
Aber dass ich jetzt nun so eine Sportkanone bin, kann ich nicht sagen.
Ok. Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja geimpft bin ich natürlich, weil ich so viel Kontakt habe mit dem Sport.
Ja geimpft bin ich natürlich, weil ich so viel Kontakt mit anderen Menschen habe.
Da gucke ich schon, dass ich regelmäßig alle Impfungen habe.
Ok. Und waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Im Ausland war ich schon lange nicht mehr. Nein, ich habe schon lange keine große Urlaubsreise gemacht.
Ok. Frau Winter, gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen, von denen Sie wissen?
Ja, also meine Mutter hat tatsächlich eine Darmerkrankung.
Darmerkrankung?
Ja und zwar, das heißt Morbus Crohn. Das ist so eine, ja also sie hat immer wieder Probleme mit dem Darm.
Ok. Und Ihre Vater?
Ja, mein Vater, der ist vor einem Jahr gestorben.
Der hat gelitten unter heftigen Gichtanschälen.
Der hat aber auch sehr viel Alkohol getrunken.
Und letztendlich hatte der eine Blutvergiftung.
Ja, daran ist er letztendlich gestorben.
Ja, es tut mir leid. Wann hatte er gestorben?
Vor einem Jahr war das.
Ok. Haben Sie Geschwister, Frau Winter?
Ja, ich habe zwei Schwestern.
Ok. Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, wir sehen uns nicht so oft, aber eigentlich sind die gesund, ja.
Ok. Also soweit Sie wissen leiden Sie nicht an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Nee, also ich wüsste nicht, dass da irgendjemand was hat.
Ok. Frau Winter, ich habe noch eine Frage. Haben Sie auch Bauchkrämpfe?
Also ja, manchmal wenn ich Durchfall habe, habe ich halt ein bisschen Bauchkrämpfe.
Und halt im Rahmen dieser Endometriose. Wenn ich meine Periode habe, dann sind die Krämpfe schon ein bisschen mehr.
Ok. Und wenn Sie Durchfall haben, wie sieht Ihre Stuhl aus? Haben Sie Blut im Stuhl gesehen?
Nee, Blut ist da garantiert nicht drin. Das ist immer nur so halb verdautes Zeug.
Und ja, das ist halt wässriger als normal.
Ok. Frau Winter, da sind die Fragen, die ich Ihnen vorstellen wollte. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Sie haben mich ja jetzt so viele Sachen gefragt und ich habe Ihnen so viel erzählt, was ich jetzt gerne wissen möchte natürlich.
Was ist los und wo kommt dieses Herzrasen her und auch diese komischen Unwahrtsanfälle?
Das ist ja ein bisschen bedrohliches Gefühl. Das kann man sich ja irgendwie nicht erlauben so im Berufsleben.
Und was kann man dagegen machen? Das ist die Frage.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass Sie ein bisschen Sorgen machen.
Dass Sie sich Sorgen machen. Wir werden erst bestimmt feststellen, was mit Ihnen los ist.
Aber dafür brauche ich noch ein bisschen Geduld, damit ich mit meinem Oberärzt sprechen kann.
Ich bitte Sie im Wartezimmer ein bisschen zu warten. Dann komme ich wieder zurück.
Ich mache körperliche Untersuchungen und ein paar Laboruntersuchungen, um Blut abzunehmen.
Laboruntersuchungen, ok. Ja, ok. Dann warte ich jetzt im Wartezimmer.
Ja, ja. Und bis dann, Frau Winter.
Ja, bis gleich. Ok, das war's.
Wunderbar. Möchte noch jemand irgendwas Zusätzliches wissen von der Frau Winter?
Ja, wie sehen die Haare, Haut, Nägel aus?
Die Haare sind ein bisschen struppig.
Die Nägel, ich meine, die bei der Arbeit brechen die natürlich leicht mal ab.
Ich muss die immer ziemlich kurz schneiden.
Gibt es noch andere Fragen? Ich würde sagen, Sie haben sehr erschöpfend abgefragt.
Ja, da kommt was.
Herr Wichmann, Frau Wichmann.
Frau Wichmann, ja, genau.
Könnten Sie bitte struppig schreiben in den Chat?
Ihre Haare, Ihre Haare, oder Sie haben gesagt, meine Haare sind struppig.
Ihre Haare sind ein bisschen struppig.
Das heißt, ein bisschen trocken.
Ok, können Sie...
Aha, ok, danke.
Das ist aber eher auf den Augenblick bezogen. So wie Sie jetzt tatsächlich aussehen.
Frau Wichmann, ist Ihnen eine Hitzeunverträglichkeit oder schlechtes vertragende Wärme oder Kälte aufgefallen?
Ja, also jetzt diese plötzliche Wärme, dass es mit einem mal so sehr warm geworden ist, das konnte ich nicht so gut vertragen.
Das stimmt ja. Das ging mir zu schnell sozusagen.
Und haben Sie vielleicht bemerkt, eine Konzentrationsstörung?
Konzentrieren Sie sich?
Ja, ich habe ja gesagt, so ein bisschen unruhig fühle ich mich, nervös.
Ja, aber so richtig schlimme Konzentrationsstörungen. Ich muss mich bei der Arbeit ja...
Ich muss ja nicht so aufmerksam sein. Ich muss ja nicht irgendwelche Listen vergleichen. Das läuft schon im Alltag.
Danke.
Möchte ich jemanden noch was fragen? Aber Ihr Mikro ist nicht an.
Fühlen Sie sich nervös und haben Sie das bemerkst an den Händen?
Ja, habe ich auch gesagt.
Dankeschön.
Ja, Doktor Puppe hat es gesagt. Genau. Frau Doktor, sagen Sie Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind.
Also, ok.
Ja, also wir fragen erst mal ab, ob noch Fragen sind. Sonst, wie gesagt, Sie können auch noch weiter überlegen. Ja, jetzt kommt noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie eine Hautveränderung? Ich meine trockene Haut oder nebeschwörde?
Ja, trockene Haut habe ich immer schon. Also ich muss immer kremen. Ja, das ist aber nicht neu, ne?
Früher haben Sie Schiftruiseprobleme gehabt.
Was für Probleme?
Schiftruiseunterfunktionen oder Oberfunktionen. Erinnern Sie sich?
Da weiß ich nichts von. Ok.
Also in der Familie hat es niemand. Ok.
Kann es losgehen?
Ja, kann es losgehen. Also, ok.
Hallo Herr Doktor Oberärztin. Ich habe eine neue Patiente aufgenommen. Ich würde Sie gerne vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Unsere Patenten heißt Nadia Winter. Frau Nadia Winter ist 46 Jahre alt, ist 1,67 Meter hoch und wiegt 71 Kilogramm.
Frau Winter habe heute Morgen ein heftiges Herzphasen. Das war das erste Mal und vorher hatte sie so etwas, sie hatte berichtet, dass das erste Mal geschehen ist.
Außerdem fügte sie hin zu, dass sie in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen zweimal ohnmächtig, zweimal ihre Bewusstsein verloren hat. Die Bewusstsein habe ungefähr zwei Minuten gedauert.
Die Bewusstlosigkeit?
Ja, die Bewusstlosigkeit hat ungefähr zwei Minuten gedauert. Außerdem beschwert sie über Einschlafstörungen und Nervosität. Sie leidet unter Durchfällen.
Das ist ein sehr guter Begriff.
Ein sehr guter Begriff?
Ja, das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Die Diarrhea?
Ja, die Diarrhea. Sie leidet unter Diarrhea in den letzten Wochen. Sie hat auch gelegentlich Bauchkrämpfe und sie berichtet, dass sie in den letzten drei Monaten ungefähr wegen dieser Diarrhea 3 Kilogramm abgenommen hat.
Und die Blut im Stuhl habe sie nicht gesehen. Und die Fragen nach Atemnot, Husten, Fieber, also nach Schweißschüttelfrost wurden verneint und ihre Appetit sei normal.
Und Frau Winter leider an Endometriose seit 28 Jahren und nimmt dagegen Minolith ein, aber die Dosis ist eher nicht bekannt. Sie hat auch keine Probleme mit ihrer Regelblutung.
Und es kann ja auch nicht sein, sie berichtet, dass sie keine Chance hat, schwanger zu sein.
Und als sie ein Kind war, ist bei ihnen eine Translektomie mit 10 Jahren durchgeführt und eine Appendektomie mit 17 Jahren durchgeführt. Und als Medikamenten nehme sie ab und zu bald ihren Tropfen, also bei Bedarf.
Bei Frau Winter sei eine Allergie bekannt. Sie reagiert allergisch auf braunes Pflaster und sie hat rote Pickelchen. Sie reagiert mit rote Pickelchen darauf.
Sie hat also Utikaria nehme ich an und sie hat keine Unverträglichkeiten. Sie hat mit Rauchen vor 3 Jahren aufgehaut, aber vorher hat sie 12 Jahre lang ca. 6 Zigaretten pro Tag geraucht.
Und sie trinke gelegentlich Alkohol, mit Drogen hat sie keinen Kontakt. Mit Drogen habe sie keinen Kontakt. Und als Sport fährt sie Fahrrad gelegentlich.
Sie hat eine Unabhängigkeit. Sie hat einen Impfstatus vollständig. Sie war unaufwendlich. Sie hat eine Gichtkontaktion. Sie ist vor einem Jahr gestorben. Sie berichtete, dass sie wegen Alkoholabusus gestorben ist.
Gicht ist doch Fachbegriff. Gibt es lateinische Namen? Das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein. Mir fällt ja gerade auch nicht ein. Ich überlege gerade.
Es heißt irgendwas. Arthritis Eureka oder Podiatris? Ja genau. Arthritis Eureka. Irgendwas mit Eureka, das war mir klar. Aber was da vorne weg war, wusste ich nicht mehr.
Ja ok, jetzt habe ich mich auch daran erinnert. Und ihre Mutter leidet an Mobus Crohn. Ihre Schwester ist gesund, soweit sie weiß. Sie ist eine ledige Frau, aber sie lebt mit ihren Freunden zusammen. Frau Winter habe keine Kinder und sie arbeitet als Schuhverkäuferin.
Ah ja ok. Ok, und das war's. Ja, was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung? Also mir fällt eigentlich nicht etwas genaues ein. Aber es kann ja auch eine chronische Darmentzündung sein. Also wie ihre Mutter Crohn oder Ulcerative Colitis.
Und sonst fällt mir nichts ein. Denken Sie nochmal nach. Sie ist unruhig und zitterig. Sie hat Gewicht abgenommen. Sie hat Einschlafstörungen. Sie kann Wärme nicht so gut vertragen.
Ja, also das kann auch eine... Also sie kann auch in Wechseljahren sein. Ja, das meine ich jetzt nicht. Ja gut, wäre auch eine Idee. Und Unruhe. Sie hat auch berichtet, dass sie Zitter habe. Das kann eine hypokämische Attacke sein.
Aber ein Kollege hat eigentlich noch eine gezielte Nachfrage gehabt. Ja, die Hypothyrose. Ja, es kann auch eine Hypothyrose sein.
Gut, also Zuckerengleisung haben wir gehabt. Hypertereose haben wir gehabt. Und Sie haben gesagt, als erste Diagnose haben Sie vermutet, was war das?
Also Crohn-Cedarm-Erkrankung. Sie hat ja ab und zu Diarrhohe. Ja genau. Was machen Sie mit der Patientin denn diagnostisch?
Also ich würde sie erst natürlich körperlich untersuchen. Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Also ich würde erst natürlich eine Bauchuntersuchung machen und ich werde auch die Schiffdrüsen abtasten.
Ist Ihnen noch wie Sie das machen? Ja, ich soll mich hinter den Patienten einstellen und nach vorne die Schiffdrüsen vorsichtig abtasten.
Und schlucken lassen. Ich frage das deshalb, weil das eine klassische Prüferfrage ist. Fragen die gerne immer.
Gut, Sie tasten die Schiffdrüse ab und was machen Sie noch? Dann werde ich natürlich Blut abnehmen. Was machen Sie noch vorher noch?
Und ich würde auch das Herz abhören. Sie hat ja gesagt, dass Sie Herzrasen hatte.
Natürlich würde ich auch eine EKG durchführen, damit ich ausschließen kann, ob es eine Herzkrankheit gibt.
Ja und? Ja, jetzt wollten Sie Blut abnehmen? Ja, dann nehme ich natürlich Blut ab. Und was bestimmen Sie im Blut?
Also ich würde erst die entzündlichen Parameter kontrollieren und natürlich die T3, T4 und TSH Hormone gucken, also messen.
Und natürlich auch die Langzeitglucose HbA1c würde ich auch testen. Bestimmen. Und ich werde auch ein Blutbild machen.
Ja klar. Gut. Was wäre dann eine weiterführende technische Untersuchung möglicherweise?
Also EKG machen wir noch unbedingt und wir müssen auch die Schiffdrüsen-Sonografie machen.
Genau. Ja, sehr gut. Falls es nötig ist, können wir auch eine Biopsie nehmen.
Genau, stimmt. Wenn sich da was zeigt. Wenn es sich jetzt bestätigen würde, dass die Patientin tatsächlich eine Schilddrüsenüberfunktion hat, was wäre denn dann die Therapie?
Also für Schiffdrüsen gibt es nur zwei Medikamente, die ich weiß. Eine ist Propyl-Tio-Urasil und andere fängt mit M. Aber das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Also sind Thyrostatika jedenfalls, oder? Medikamente, die die Schiffdrüse bremsen.
Ja, die Schiffdrüsenhormone hemmen. Genau. Und ich würde auch Mitmazol. Es gibt ja nur zwei Medikamente.
Und ich würde auch eine Beto Blocker verschreiben für die Herzrasen. Stimmt, ja gute Idee.
Ja, und ich würde am ersten würde diese reichen. Genau. Und dann muss man weiter gucken, ob das ausreicht oder ob sie nach wie vor, dann muss man eine weitere Therapie einplanen.
Ja, was wären nächste Schritte, denkbare Schritte? Also sie sollen nochmal zu Kontroll kommen.
Ja, aber wenn sich dann zeigt, dass die Beschwerden immer noch da sind, dass die Thyrostatiker alleine nicht helfen, was wäre dann der nächste Schritt, der denkbare Schritt?
Also es kann ja auch um eine Krebs, um eine Tumor gehen. Genau, das wäre auch ein Gedanke, ja. Aber was für Therapieoptionen haben wir noch?
Also, chirurgische Therapie. Die chirurgische und dann die nächste, die hier gerade eben? Ja, Jodtherapie.
Radiojodtherapie. Ja, die können wir als chirurgische Schiffdrüsen entfernen. Oder das, genau. Gut, ja wunderbar.
Ja, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über Ihre Untersuchungsergebnisse bei der Frau Winter.
Gerne. Ja, okay. Gut. Also Sie haben natürlich sprachlich so gut wie überhaupt gar keine Probleme.
Das einzige, was mir aufgefallen ist, obwohl Sie so super gut Deutsch sprechen, Sie machen ständig äh, aber richtig doll.
Und das merken Sie wahrscheinlich nicht. Wir machen das alle, das wissen Sie, wir machen das auch alle ziemlich häufig, aber Sie machen es wirklich extrem oft.
Und das brauchen Sie gar nicht. Sie wissen ja alle Wörter. Sie brauchen diese Kunstpause gar nicht. Ja?
Hochen Sie mal rein in die Aufzeichnung von heute. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das ohne Weiteres abhören können.
Ja, ich will können. Wenn das geht, denn das ist wirklich signifikant, wie oft Sie das machen.
Und damit zerstören Sie den guten Eindruck, den Sie sonst machen mit Ihrer Sprache. Sie haben ja überhaupt gar keine Sprachprobleme.
So, dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass Sie diese Standardformulierung haben Sie ziemlich oft verwendet haben.
Sie haben ja praktisch Ihre ganze Liste praktisch abgewandelt. Haben Sie das, haben Sie jenes, haben Sie Verdauungsprobleme, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Versuchen Sie da noch ein paar alternative Formulierungen sich anzugewöhnen einfach. Ist Ihnen aufgefallen das?
Haben Sie bemerkt? Ja oder oder? Okay, okay.
Also einfach, dass man das noch mal ein bisschen hat sich oder hat sich Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit verändert.
Nicht, da haben Sie Gewicht verloren oder haben Sie abgenommen.
So, dass man noch mal irgendwie eine andere Formulierung hat, damit es nicht ganz so eintönig ist.
Und dann ein kleiner Klassiker. Beim Vater haben Sie gefragt, wann hat er gestorben? Nein, wann ist er gestorben?
Ja, okay, ich habe ich hat gesagt. Ja, es ist aber glaube ich echt ein Versehen gewesen.
Also wie gesagt sprachlich macht Ihnen ja keiner was vor. Das Elb, das sollten Sie ab, sollten Sie wirklich abstellen.
Versuchen Sie es. Lassen Sie sich mal, lassen Sie sich von irgendjemanden, mit dem Sie zusammenleben oder so aufzeichnen oder unterbrechen.
Hier, da hast du schon wieder gesagt. Man merkt das ja nicht. Man macht das so unbewusst.
Und wie gesagt, wir alle machen das. Ich mache das auch. Und wenn ich jetzt das reklamiere, dann nehme ich mich sehr zusammen, dass ich versuche,
kein Äder zwischenzumachen, weil ich es natürlich auch ständig tue.
Ja, ich habe verstanden, was Sie meinen.
Aber ich muss mich sehr kontrollieren, um das nicht zu machen. Nur bei Ihnen war es wirklich ziemlich krass. Das ist eigentlich schade.
Sie reden ja wirklich fließend perfekt wunderbar, fast ohne Akzent. Also alles gut. Augenblick. Eine Sache.
Ja, was keiner gefragt hat, das ist die Geschichte mit dem Kloßgefühl im Hals.
Wenn man also Richtung Schildrüse denkt, könnte man das fragen. Ist Ihnen das aufgefallen, dass Ihnen das Schlucken manchmal schwerfällt oder so?
Aber Sie waren auf der Schiene mit der Schildrüse gar nicht.
Aber wenn man in diese Richtung nachfragt, das wäre noch möglich.
Da hätte möglicherweise die Patientin auch noch einen Hinweis geben können. Aber wenn man da nicht nachgefragt wird, sagt man das auch nicht.
Würde ich sagen. Man gewöhnt sich ja an sowas. Man merkt, dass man beim Schlucken mit ein bisschen Widerstand hat.
Ja, das ist jetzt halt so. Das sind ja alles Sachen, die immer so langsam sich entwickeln.
Und wann fängt es an, dass man es registriert und dass man sagt, hey, da ist was nicht in Ordnung.
Das ist ja eigentlich so eine Schwelle, wo man sagt, jetzt merke ich, dass was unangenehm ist.
Gut. Mehr kann ich eigentlich zu Ihrer Anamnese nicht sagen. Sie haben die ja natürlich top gemacht.
Top gefragt und Top-Präsentation. Und natürlich war es die Reporteriore.
Natürlich war es die Reporteriore. Ja klar. Ich dachte schon, der Fall wäre ein bisschen zu banal und zu einfach, weil die Spur, die mir gelegt ist, ja eigentlich sehr breit ist.
Aber ja, es gibt noch Herausforderungen. Ja, wunderbar.
Gut. Okay. Vielen, vielen Dank. Frau Südmann. Ja. Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Natürlich. Wegen Anamnesebogen. Wir haben Fragen über, haben Sie oder ist Ihnen Allergien bekannt?
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit? Zum Beispiel, wie kann man erklären zwischen Allergien und Unverträglichkeit Unterschiede?
Ja. Vielleicht der Patient fragt, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Allergien und Unverträglichkeit? Wie können wir erzählen?
Ja, auch in der Simulation frage ich ja manchmal so ein bisschen verständnislos. Ja, ich habe doch gesagt, ich habe keine anderen Allergien.
Also eigentlich geht es ja bei Unverträglichkeiten in der Regel um Nahrungsmittelunverträglichkeiten.
Und Allergien, das sind ja diese exogenen Sachen wie zum Beispiel Pollen oder Hausstaubmilben.
Das sind die Sachen, die wir einatmen, die wir eben auch andere Weise irgendwie in Kontakt kommen oder auch Hautkontaktallergien.
Ja, es gibt Leute, die haben Medikamentallergie, Chemialergie.
Ja, klar, das sind Kontaktallergien oder spezielle Medikamentenallergien, die ja häufig auch sehr dramatisch verlaufen, diese Medikamentenallergien.
Und wobei ich da zum Beispiel auch nicht sagen kann, wo ist da die Unverträglichkeit und wo ist da die Allergie?
Also ich denke mal, die Unverträglichkeit ist eigentlich eher im Bereich der Ernährung, dass man sagt, gibt es irgendwelche Nahrungsmittel, die sie überhaupt nicht vertragen?
Und dann kommt natürlich immer der Klassiker mit der Milch für die Laktoseintoleranz.
Dann kommt die Nachfrage nach der Glutenunverträglichkeit.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie Brot oder Nudeln nicht besonders gut vertragen können?
Und dann gibt es natürlich auch diese Reizdarmgeschichten, dass Leute eben erklären, wenn ich rohes Gemüse esse, dann kriege ich ganz schnell Blehungen und Durchfall und solche Geschichten.
Aber ich glaube, das ist vielleicht so am ehesten diese Unterscheidung.
Medikamente, chemische Stoffe, Sachen, die wir einatmen oder die wir mit der Haut aufnehmen, auf der einen Seite.
Also da haben wir diese Pflasterallergie. Ich war übrigens, Frau Dr. Sahid, Ihnen sehr dankbar, dass Sie das mit der Allergie auf braunes Pflaster haben Sie sehr schön gesagt.
Denn manche Kollegen machen da so eine braune Pflasterallergie draus und das gibt es nicht. Eine braune Allergie haben wir nicht.
Sondern es ist eine Allergie auf braunes Pflaster.
Das sind diese Sachen, die von außen an uns herangetragen werden und das andere sind die Lebensmittel, die wir essen, die andere Leute eben gut vertragen und die mir Schwierigkeiten machen aufgrund meines speziellen Enzymsystems.